В ефірі новини дня з Митрієм Зіріним.
Усім доброго вечора. Про новини спорту
сьогодні розповість Крістін Отто.
Доброго вечора.
Сьогоднішні теми випуску:
Значне підвищення заробітної плати:
спілка «IG Metall» хоче
домогтися підвищення зарплати на 7-8%
для працівників металургійної
та електротехнічної промисловості.
Якими будуть ваші дії, пане президенте?
Втративши абсолютну більшість,
глава Франції Макрон
тепер змушений шукати партнерів у парламенті.
Переломний момент у Колумбії:
Густаво Петро - перший із партії «Лівих»,
хто в новітній історії країни
підкорив президентський палац.
Протягом багатьох тижнів уряд
присягає нам у важкі часи.
Ми теж відчуємо труднощі війни
і допоможемо пом’якшити вплив
в економічному плані.
Рекордні ціни на енергоносії та темпи інфляції
говорять самі за себе.
Потрібно встановити баланс.
Саме тому найбільша німецька
профспілка «﻿IG Metall»
вимагає  підвищити заробітну плату
працівникам галузі на сім-вісім%.
Про це розповість Штефан Шлоссер.
Металотехнічна та електротехнічна галузі,
у яких залучено близько 3,8 млн працівників,
є основою німецької промисловості.
Після декількох років очікування
та з огляду на рівень інфляції
«﻿IG Metall» вимагає суттєвого підвищення
заробітної плати на період одного року.
Навантаженість, замовлення та прибутки в галузі
набагато кращі, ніж можна було
передбачити в червні 2021 року.
І незважаючи на нестабільність, ми припускаємо,
що розвиток буде і надалі позитивним.
Штефан Вольф не поділяє такі погляди.
Він є президентом «Gesamtmetall»
і водночас очолює компанію з постачання
автозапчастин «Elring Klinger»,
де працевлаштовані близько
9500 співробітників у всьому світі.
Про хороший заробіток в галузі
не може бути й мови.
Адже маємо проблеми
з високими цінами на сировину,
енергоносії та проблеми в ланцюжку поставок.
Чимало компаній
перебувають у скрутному становищі
із загрозою для власного існування.
Високий рівень інфляції, до цього ще й
високі вимоги до заробітної плати.
Якщо ціни на товари та заробітна плата
продовжуватимуть зростати,
тоді цей круговий процес під загрозою.
З погляду економіки
нам потрібна компенсація
втрати купівельної спроможності.
З іншого ж боку, ми хочемо уникнути цього
кругового процесу від заробітної плати до вартості.
Одноразові виплати - хороше рішення,
оскільки вони знімають певний тиск.
Але цього для «﻿IG Metall» недостатньо,
члени спілки вимагають вищу заробітну плату
на постійній основі.
Переговори розпочнуться у вересні,
це буде запекла боротьба.
Перемовини супроводжуватимуться
напруженою суперечкою.
Питання енергетики обговорює і
«світлофорна» коаліція.
Через обмежені поставки газу з Росії
міністр економіки Габек зазначив,
що дедалі більше він буде покладатися
на вугілля для виробництва електроенергії.
Така стратегія викликала
критику з боку опозиції,
але плани співуправління FDP
також не заходять далеко.
Про це розповість Патриція Відемайєр.
Ситуація надзвичайно напружена,
сховища майже порожні.
Через «Північний потік-1» до Німеччини
буде надходити навіть менше газу, ніж очікувалося.
Сьогодні опівдні оприлюднили результат
зустрічі міністрів енергетики усіх земель
із федеральним міністром економіки.
Ми проведемо ревізію на початку липня.
Це означає, що постачання буде відсутнє
щонайменше 10 днів.
Це може призвести
до використання газу зі сховищ.
Новини невтішні.
У Берліні загострюються дебати
щодо альтернативи газу,
FDP вимагає розглянути й
фрекінг і ядерну енергетику.
Важливо, щоб три атомні електростанції,
що залишилися, пропрацювали довше.
Міністр економіки, на мій погляд,
не може ігнорувати цей факт.
Але принцип роботи атомних
електростанцій не такий простий -
не вистачає працівників, закупівля нових
паливних стрижнів потребує часу,
також необхідна перевірка безпеки.
Такі дослідження були проведені
Федеральним міністерством економіки.
Два інших партнера «світлофорної» коаліції
відмовляються від подальшого
використання ядерних реакторів.
Було зрозуміло, що
соціал-демократична держава
не підтримає дебати про розширення
ядерної енергетики чи повернення фрекінгу.
Паливо та паливні елементи відсутні.
Їх немає і швидко не отримаєш.
Тому немає сенсу проводити ці «штучні» дебати.
Наразі існує лише домовленість про те,
що вугільні електростанції мають
використовуватись не так часто.
Тео Колль веде репортаж із Берліна.
Тео, чи йдеться про початок серйозних
«світлофорних» дебатів?
Так, йдеться зокрема і про принципи, але все не
так серйозно, щоб коаліція була під загрозою.
Усім трьом «світлофорним»
партіям довелося
порушити серйозні політичні
табу через наслідки війни в Україні.
SPD боротиметься, FDP загрузне в боргах, а Зелені
захочуть знову запустити вугільну енергетику.
Цікаво те, що ціна порушення
політичних табу різна.
FDP довелось чимало заплатити за це
на державних виборах та опитуваннях.
Це ще одна причина, чому ліберали
зараз демонструють таку перевагу.
Півгодини тому у Федеральній раді
вони розглядали постанову
про бюджетну дисципліну.
Цитата: «Покінчити з надзвичайною фінансовою
політикою, повернувши боргове гальмо».
Це звучить досить жорстко. Якщо криза
наростатиме і надалі, розслабитись не вдасться.
Дякую, Тео Колль.
Серйозна невдача для президента Франції Макрона.
У майбутньому йому знадобиться
партнер по коаліції.
Хоча центристський альянс Макрона «Ensemble»
із 245-ма місцями залишається найсильнішим,
усе ж втрачає абсолютну більшість.
На другому місці - ліворадикальна група
Жана-Люка Меланшона «Nupes»
із 131 місцем.
Справа на графіці Марін ле Пен,
яка має у майбутньому парламенті
більше місць, ніж будь-коли раніше.
На четвертому місці - консерватори
та їхні союзники.
Анне Аренд веде репортаж із Парижа.
Куди рухається Франція?
Невизначеність наступного дня після виборів
президенту не на користь.
Тому що тепер Макрону
доводиться для кожного проєкту
шукати союзників
з інших політичних таборів.
Сам він досі не коментував результат виборів,
але його прем'єрміністерка
увечері виборів заявила:
Ми зробимо все можливе,
щоб сформувати ефективну більшість.
Немає альтернативи, щоб гарантувати
стабільність нашої країни
та розпочати необхідні реформи.
Незрозуміло, як він зможе це зробити
і чи зможе взагалі.
Один з варіантів -
союз із правоцентристською
партією «﻿Les Républicains».
Але вони стверджують свою опозиційну роль.
Ми дотримуємося цієї позиції.
Немає сумніву, що ми укладаємо пакт,
створюємо коаліцію
чи укладаємо будь-які інші домовленості.
Популістські партії, як ліві, так і праві,
вийшли з виборів у особливо сильних позиціях.
Але тут все зрозуміло: вони категорично
відкидають реформи Макрона,
як наприклад, щодо пенсії.
Натомість діють впевнено.
Праві націоналісти на чолі з Марін Ле Пен,
які на диво посіли третє місце,
вимагають провідні посади.
Тепер у нас є абсолютно нові засоби
захисту наших політичних цілей.
Стримування хаотичної імміграції,
а також підвищення купівельної спроможності.
Результати виборів роблять це можливим.
Ніколи раніше ми не були настільки сильно
представлені у парламенті.
Чи є зараз блокада в Національних зборах?
Пошук президентом партнера,
найімовірніше, буде складним.
Францію чекають політично нестабільні часи.
Для президента Франції більше
немає комфортного правління.
Томас Вальде із репортажем з Парижа. Як
результати виборів вплинуть на Німеччину
та на Європу загалом?
Відповідно до французької конституції
зовнішня політика є компетенцією президента.
Тобто вчорашній результат не має прямого впливу
на зовнішню політику Франції
та на міжнародні відносини.
Макрон втратив довіру,
тому йому доведеться витратити
багато часу та енергії,
щоб створити умови, за яких
він зможе керувати країною,
а цього часу та енергії
зовнішній політиці не вистачає.
Позиція глав держав і урядів на міжнародній арені
також залежить від їхньої напористості
всередині власної країни.
Важко уявити ініціювання та впровадження
реформ Макроном на європейському рівні,
коли йому це не вдається зробити у своїй країні.
У нього непочатий край роботи тут,
це означає, що вибори мають непрямий вплив,
Макрон більше не може так вільно грати
на міжнародній арені, як раніше.
Такі підсумки підбив
Томас Вальде у Парижі, дякую.
Президент України Зеленський побоюється,
що російські напади можуть стати
ще жорстокішими в найближчі дні.
Пояснює це тим, що ЄС, можливо,
оголосить Україну кандидатом
на членство вже на цьому тижні.
Україна говорить про вирішальні битви.
Росія здебільшого бомбить лінії
фронту на Сході та Північному сході.
І все ж люди в Україні продовжують
намагатись вести повсякденний спосіб життя.
Ніна Куршільґен.
Дитячі посмішки посеред бомб та війни.
Волонтери їздять від однієї
гарячої точки до іншої
для того, щоб діти бодай на хвилинку
відволіклися від своїх похмурих буднів
завдяки фокусам, музиці та подарункам.
Ця вечірка така класна.
Дуже крута ідея, адже відколи почалася війна,
практично жодних розваг немає.
Вони роблять нас щасливими.
Ось так виглядають реалії війни.
Російська сторона демонструє ці кадри,
які свідчать про «позитивний розвиток»
їхнього наступу.
На цій мапі ви можете побачити реальні території,
захоплені Росією та російськими сепаратистами
за останні 30 днів.
Президент України
Володимир Зеленський заявив,
що напади можуть посилюватися.
Очевидно, що варто очікувати від Росії посилення
ворожої активності
спеціально та показово саме цього тижня.
І не тільки проти України,
а й проти інших країн Європи.
Ми готуємося, ми готові.
На відвойованих Україною територіях
тонни боєприпасів, що не вибухнули -
площа таких територій майже дорівнює
розмірам сучасної Німеччини.
Загалом 85 000 вибухонебезпечних боєприпасів,
фактично усюди - на дитячих майданчиках,
просто на вулицях і навіть у будинках.
Щодня сапери шукають та знешкоджують їх.
Сподіваючись, що на ці вулиці
одного дня знову повернеться мирне життя.
Через розв'язання війни в Україні на Росію
було накладено численні санкції,
до яких цього разу приєдналася
і прокуратура Мюнхена.
У Німеччині вперше
конфіскували майно російського подружжя.
Власником трьох квартир у Мюнхені
виявився підсанкційний депутат Держдуми РФ.
Виставка сучасного мистецтва «Documenta»,
що традиційно проходить у місті Кассель,
розпочалася зі скандалу та
закидів щодо антисемітизму.
Організатори виставки потрапили
під шквал жорсткої критики.
Причиною став банер
групи митців із Індонезії.
За словами міністерки культури Клаудії Рот,
на банері присутня антисемітська символіка.
Навіть мистецтво має певні межі.
Організатори виставки заперечують
будь-який зв'язок із антисемітькою тематикою -
повідомив президент Центральної ради євреїв
Німеччини Йозеф Шустер.
Очікувані новини з Ізраїлю.
УрядІзраїлю готує
законопроєкт про розпуск кнесету,
коаліція правих, ліберальних та
арабських партій розпалася.
В Ізраїлі відбудуться
позачергові вибори до парламенту.
Відповідно до коаліційної угоди
замість Нафталі Бенета, ймовірно,
тимчасово обов'язки прем'єр-міністра Ізраїлю
виконуватиме глава МЗС та
засновник партії Єш Атід Яір Лапід.
З нами на зв'язку Майкл Беверунге з Тель-Авіва.
Майкле, що означатимуть ці вибори для Ізраїлю?
Насправді уряд був приречений
ще з самого початку.
Він давно втратив більшість у парламенті.
Тому рішення Бенета та Лапіда
було радше актом відчаю,
аніж звичайним розпуском.
Недовговічність такої коаліції була очевидною,
зокрема, через численні суперечності, які були
помітними з самого початку.
Наприклад, вперше в історії до уряду увійшла
арабська ісламістська партія.
Зрештою коаліцію залишила
більшість ізраїльських іудеїв,
а також велика кількість ізраїльських
та палестинських арабів.
Тому доля сумнозвісної коаліції насправді є
відображенням внутрішніх негараздів
розділеної країни та розділеного регіону.
Дякуємо. З нами був
Майкл Беверунге з Тель-Авіва.
А зараз поговоримо про Південну Америку.
У Колумбії обрали нового президента.
Густаво Петро став першим «лівим» політиком,
якому вдалося обійняти найвищу державну посаду.
У другому турі виборів Петро отримав 50,4% голосів,
а його опонент, будівельний
магнат Родольфо Ернандес - 47,3%.
Петро дісталася соціально та політично
розділена країна.
Однією з найважливіших цілей новообраного
президента є примирення народу.
Більше розповість Крістоф Рокерат.
Обрання Петро на посаду президента
стало переломним моментом в історії Колумбії.
Вперше в історії президентське крісло
дістається соціалісту та колишньому члену
партизанського руху М-19.
Його перші слова після перемоги
не про боротьбу, а про примирення.
Це означає, по-перше, мир, по-друге,
соціальну справедливість,
і по-третє, справедливість
щодо навколишнього середовища.
Зрештою вибори минули
цивілізованіше, ніж очікувалося.
Опонент Петро мільйонер Ернандес,
політична позиція якого не зовсім зрозуміла,
відразу визнав свою поразку.
Це важливий сигнал для країни,
яка після понад 30-річної громадянської війни
досі бореться з насильством, тобто мир у якій
надзвичайно крихкий та нестабільний.
Густаво Петро відмовився від збройної боротьби
вже кілька десятиліть тому.
Він сидів у в'язниці, зазнавав тортур,
а згодом пішов у політику, ставши мером Боготи
та працюючи дипломатом у Бельгії.
Петро доведеться тяжко працювати над своєю
метою - об'єднанням країни,
яка розділена не лише політично, але й
страждає від економічної нерівності.
Великі сподівання народ покладає
також і на Франсію Маркес,
яка стала першою темношкірою жінкою,
обраною на посаду віцепрезидентки.
Ми створимо уряд тих, чиї руки вкриті
мозолями від праці,
тих, хто ходить босоніж, тих, хто
був забутий та покинутий.
Колумбія обрала шлях змін.
Завдання нової влади - втілити їх у реальність.
Після пекельних пожеж на вихідних
німці невимовно зраділи дощу.
З особливим полегшенням зітхнули у Бранденбурзі.
Лісові пожежі на південному
заході від Берліна наразі під контролем.
Ситуація поблизу Троєнбрітцена і Беліца,
за даними влади, значно поліпшилася.
Сотні жителів можуть повернутися до своїх домівок.
Проте за вугільними залишками
варто стежити й надалі.
Головною причиною пожеж стали
сильні вітри, що ніяк не стихали.
А зараз поговоримо про чемпіонат світу
з водних видів спорту,
який проходить цьогоріч у Будапешті,
та його медалістів, звісно ж, Крістін?
Завтра ввечері очікуємо на фінальний заплив
вітчизняної зірки - Флоріана Веллброка,
який фінішував другим у плаванні
на дистанції 800 м вільним стилем,
поступившись українському плавцеві
Михайлу Романчукові, який від початку війни
тренувався з ним у Магдебурзі.
Незважаючи на проходження до фіналу
чемпіонату світу,
Флоріан Веллброк не надто
задоволений своїм результатом.
7 хв 44,75 с - занадто повільно.
Так, він лише на 0,05с поступився
Михайлу Романчуку, плавцеві з України.
Завтра відбудеться фінальний заплив
на 800 м, у якому також візьме участь
олімпійський чемпіон Олімпіади-2020
американець Боббі Фінке.
Лукас Мертенс вибув сьогодні вранці на
800-метрівці, незважаючи на квітневий рекорд.
Він бере участь у запливах на різних дистанціях,
так, годину тому фінішував сьомим у фіналі
на дистанції 200 м вільним стилем.
Після здобутого «срібла» на ЧС
вчора на дистанції 400 м вільним стилем
йому забракло дихання.
Вже скоро, близько 20:00, зможе
випробувати свої шанси на золото Анна Елендт.
Продемонструвавши найкращий результат у
півфіналі на дистанції 100 м брасом,
20-річна спортсменка стала фавориткою букмекерів.
Надзвичайно цікаво!
Шість перемог у дев'яти перегонах -
чудові передумови для здобуття другого
чемпіонського титулу Формули-1.
Результати Макса Ферстаппена
стають дедалі кращими.
Сильний спортсмен, та не менш чудовий стратег,
Ферстаппен лишає своїх суперників у Монреалі далеко позаду.
Після перемоги Макса Ферстаппена на Гран-прі Канади
в команді «Red Bull» видихнули з полегшенням.
З початку перегонів Ферстаппен відверто
перемагав, постійно збільшуючи свою перевагу.
Аж поки Юкі Цунода не припустився фатальної
помилки на 51-му колі з 70,
та не перейшов у режим машини безпеки.
Так, під час рестарту відстань між
суперниками суттєво зменшилася.
Макс Ферстаппен знову опинився
під величезним тиском,
однак чемпіон світу пройшов
це випробовування гідно.
24-річний голландець перемагає
Карлоса Сайнса-молодшого з команди «Ferrari»
та Льюїса Гамільтона, який брав участь у перегонах
на удосконаленій моделі «Mercedes».
Через помилки на минулих гонках Мік Шумахер
цього разу не відзначився хорошими результатами.
Пілот «Haas» посідає сьоме місце, зокрема і
через технічний дефект.
Через два тижні з'явиться нагода для реваншу
на Гран-прі Великої Британії.
Дякуємо, Крістін.
Завтра настає астрономічний початок літа.
Про погоду вже за мить
традиційно розповість Катя Горнеффер.
Близько 22:00 чекайте на новий випуск
«heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
А ми всією командою «heute» дякуємо вам
за те, що були з нами.
До зустрічі. Гарного вечора.
Добрий вечір.
Саме цей циклон спричинив виникнення
лісових пожеж у Бранденбурзі.
Наразі опади малоймовірні,
проте на узбережжі Балтійського моря
сьогодні ввечері може дощити.
В Альпах можливі грози,
однак переважатиме ясна
та дещо прохолодна погода,
температура опуститься до 11-4°C.
Між Кімгау та Верхнім Рейном вночі буде
дещо тепліше -
15-13°C.
На морі на нас завтра чекають помірні 19-20°C,
подекуди температура сягатиме 24-25°C.
На Південному заході температура
підвищиться до 28-32°C.
Завтра на нас чекає приємний літній вівторок.
Здебільшого сонячно з незначною хмарністю.
Вдень в гірських місцевостях можливі грози.
Наприклад, у Шварцвальді.
Найближчими днями
погода в країні виглядатиме так:
На Півдні потеплішає, стовпчик термометра
сягатиме 30-32°C.
На Півночі буде досить сухо та здебільшого сонячно.
Сильні грозові бурі розпочнуться не раніше п'ятниці.
Максимально температура досягатиме
від 23 до 33°C. На все добре.